We Begin this hour with new music from
singer-songwriter Margot price
[Music]
that's change of heart from Christ's new
album It's called Strays which is out
right now price says the record was
forged in the fire of many substances in
the midst of heavy personal Reckoning
she met up with Anthony as in Mason to
talk about that Journey at the Chelsea
Hotel in New York and also in Nashville
where she has made her home
can bring it looks really cool it's you
know first truck I ever bought with my
own money
for most of her music career
Margo price has had her boot on the gas
pedal going her own way you kind of
created this sort of Outlook country
image for yourself yeah it was a it was
a role you know I became it
[Music]
basically from your childhood you say
you were rebellious
where did that come from
God I wish I knew
it's been rebelling against the way that
the world is
but when covid hit and shut down her
career life got dark
you can't outrun your demons when you're
just sitting at home every night
drinking 10 white claws
you know not not 10 every time but
kind of lose track
price was struggling to make sense of
her life writing a memoir she'd call
maybe we'll make it when her editor made
an observation she said
you know whiskey is
is basically like another character in
your book yeah and I was like
[Music]
in January of 2021 as she was also
writing her new album Strays she quit
drinking
what did you see in that moment I saw
that there was more to me than this like
kind of bad girl image that I had
created
[Music]
Christ made her name in Nashville with
songs like curtain on the bus
[Music]
if her music sounded real it's cause
she'd lived the lyrics
[Music]
from Illinois price moved to Nashville
in 2003 and started playing anywhere
that would take her it says 1896 like
the spring water Supper Club and laugh
[Music]
this has been here for as long as I can
remember this is one of the only places
I could get a gig at
with her future husband Jeremy Ivey she
put a band together called buffalo
clover
[Music]
they became regulars at the Five Spot
you were trying to build a following
that soon here yeah yeah it was it was a
real scene I mean it was home it was a
second home for a while
foreign
ten Margot and Jeremy welcomed twin boys
Judah and Ezra but Ezra had a heart
defect he died two weeks after he was
born it was all I could do was just numb
those feelings well I mean and I
sometimes I I thank booze because
because it saved my life it absolutely
did if I would have had to live in that
grief I just would have been too much I
don't think you can be any more alone
than a moment like that even my husband
didn't understand yeah the grief that I
felt and I felt a lot of Shame from it
because I felt like there must have been
something wrong with me even though I
knew it was you know it was just a
genetic thing that just happens yeah
margot's marriage nearly fell apart her
band did break up and things looked
Bleak until she was suddenly signed by
Jack White's label Third Man Records is
amazing how one little thing can just
turn everything upside down one thing
it was I mean after that it was just
like
people saw me in a whole new life
[Music]
in 2016 Midwest Farmer's Daughter put
Margo price on the map the album hit
number one on the UK country chart and
number 10 here
price was even booked on Saturday Night
Live but the day before the show she
read some nasty comments on social media
there's people telling me that I needed
to get a nose job or whatever and it's
like it was my Achilles heel back then I
went out
and got annihilated I stayed up till
four in the morning
and drank every tiny bottle of liquor in
the hotel room
and did some other things too that my
editor maybe might have wiped away
[Music]
somehow she still went on the air
and nailed it yeah now I eat haters for
breakfast
[Music]
foreign
I do truly feel like quitting drinking
has been the most rebellious thing I've
ever done I've never felt better in my
life she shares it all with excruciating
honesty and maybe we'll make it I had a
panic attack when I turned in the final
draft of the book because because I was
I was worried about the Judgment I was
worried about the people hated me saying
oh you're a bad mom and you know you're
this and you're that price told her
husband she wanted to scrap the book but
he just turned to me and he said
he said you belong to no one yeah and
it's sort of interesting to hear a
husband say that I thought it was
incredible what did that mean to you
gave me all the confidence to go forward
and just
be able to be vulnerable I actually got
it tattooed on my arm since you belonged
to no one right here so I don't forget
it
[Music]
that's her husband's name go husband
Anthony you belong to Noah a couple days
before we took that truck ride Margot
celebrated two years since she's quit
drinking I said how'd you celebrate she
said I took a five mile walk and I got a
massage and I said perfect it is an
interesting it's so sorry that I'm so
sorry that people can get to you online
who don't know anything about you
they're talking about your nose your
appearance your mothering and that that
would get to her but I love showing that
she because I thought you were going to
say she didn't make it to Saturday Night
Live but
performance they should have a hangover
cure we can maybe Post online and look
gorgeous my favorite line is though eats
haters for breakfast yeah I like that
yeah you get stuff to learn how to do
that but she's done it she had a really
tough pandemic you know her daughter her
daughter Ramona was born in 2019 and
then her husband got a really bad case
of covid yeah so she said I really felt
alone raising this child things got very
dark but as you can see she credits it
actually to it she said a mushroom trip
actually is what opened her mind and
said you know what you can do this and
you can you can beat booze and you can
turn around yeah not the conventional
path out but no people better but it
works because people that do it have
said that it really does work yeah you
belong to no one yeah that was deep yeah
for breakfast that was good too